(whooshes)
(squeaks)
(melodious music)
- Congrats queen B.
- Beyonce, you are the
Madonna of our time.
- Hey Queen B, you're
gonna be a momma of twins,
- Hi Queen B congratulations
on your double bundle of joy.
(cheers)
- Our mom always said that
two was like having four
so congrats, now you have five.
- You are going to be a fantastic mother
and an amazing mother to twins.
So,
- You're gonna slay that game
just like you slay every game.
- And we are low key
hoping for gemini babies,
we're gemini twins, so cross fingers.
- We want to give you
our wonder twin power.
- So here's a little
advice from this twin duo
to your twin duo.
- Even though you might
get them the same things
and dress them alike, they're individuals,
so it's important to treat them as such.
- Hopefully no matching names.
- Right no Megan and
Reagan, no Brian and Ryan,
no Deshawn and Leshawn.
- And don't confuse their names.
- When you're dealing with
twins they're a package.
One of them gets in trouble, guess what?
The other one's in trouble too.
- Yeah.
- Beyonce, feel free to dress them alike
but always make sure it's
gonna be the same color.
- Same exact thing.
- Same exact thing, otherwise,
the other twin will always think that,
their twin has the better thing.
- No matter what it is.
- There will be times
when you do not understand
what your twins are saying.
- We speak our own language.
- Twinspeak, it's real,
be prepared for it.
- There's like a whole vocabulary just,
- Between us,
- Between us.
- Don't take sides,
you'll never win because then
they'll team up against you.
So be ready.
- By the time we were
seven, eight, et cetera,
we really started developing
our own unique style,
definitely wanted to
dress in separate outfits.
- You never can go wrong with a BOGO
when you have a twin.
- You're born with a best friend, I mean,
- Yeah.
- BFF right here.
- Chances are when
you're talking to someone
on a dating app, your twin
is also talking to them.
- You can get the dish from your twin.
- If you are getting
older and you're going out
and you're hitting the club,
you can bring them along.
And they're gonna be helping you out.
- You'll get many proposals for threesomes
but I would say be selective, you know,
don't go with the first
one that you're offered.
- Sometimes I do connect with girls better
having a twin sister.
- If your S O, does not like your twin,
forget it, they're done.
- Yeah just cut them out.
- No.
- Drake lied, when he said if I had a twin
I would still chose you.
Make sure your sister's
not looking better than you
when you're in front of your boyfriend.
- Two of his like really good friends
ended up becoming my boyfriends.
It was convenient.
- As twins you're going
to get a lot of people
who are constantly going to compare you,
oh who has the bigger eyes, who has this,
who's taller, who's bigger, who's smaller,
who's this.
- Who's smarter.
- Right.
- Don't get so caught
up on the small things
and really understand and
appreciate like the differences
that you guys have.
- You're different people,
you're unique individuals
and you should embrace
that and then the fact
that you're twins, like
this is a special bond
this isn't something
that happens everyday.
And it's pretty incredible.
- All the scratching and the hair pulling,
and the metal chairs that
we've thrown at each other
we're both still alive.
- We've survived it all.
- You have someone that will
always be your number one fan
will always laugh at your jokes.
- It works, it's a dynamic duo and
together twins can conquer the world!
(soft music)
(whooshes)
(squeaks)